no one likes getting fired but sometimes
it can be a good thing from a comedy
Queen's oscar-nominated dramatic turn to
an SNL star's breakout role as a
wisecracking cop these last minute actor
Replacements turned out to be the right
choice
the 2007 drama There Will Be Blood was
widely acclaimed upon its release and
went on to earn Daniel Day Lewis an
Academy Award for best actor but did you
know that the other lead character was
originally played by someone other than
Paul Dana
[Music]
boy
that's right the part of the charismatic
preacher Eli Sunday was first assigned
to actor and director Kell O'Neil but
after a month of shooting director Paul
Thomas Anderson decided that O'Neill
just wasn't right for the part after
O'Neill was let go Anderson didn't have
to look far to find a replacement Paul
Dano had already been cast in the film
with a smaller part as Eli's brother
Paul Sunday
Anderson was so impressed by Dano that
he decided to make the Sunday Brothers
twins this way Dino could play both
parts Dino did an impressive job with
the last minute change the actor took
only four days to prepare for the new
role which he knocked out of the park
as director Sam Taylor Johnson Was
preparing to adapt El James's
best-selling erotic drama 50 Shades of
Gray she found that casting the perfect
pair of actors to be her leads was no
easy task before eventually deciding on
Dakota Johnson for the part of Anastasia
Steele Taylor Johnson auditioned a
number of other prominent actors in the
role she even offered the part to Game
of Thrones star Emilia Clark who turned
it down due to the nudity required for
the role of 27 year old billionaire
Christian Gray a number of Hollywood's
Leading Men were considered or even
offered the part including Robert
Pattinson and Ryan Gosling in September
of 2013 it was announced that Charlie
Hunnam had been chosen for the part of
Christian you know it was a big
commitment and I wanted to make sure
that he you know that that bringing him
to life felt right and felt like it was
in my bones then less than a month
before filming started Hunan was forced
to drop out of the movie due to
scheduling conflicts with his popular
television series Sons of Anarchy as a
result The film's Producers held another
Lightning Fast round of auditions for
the part with Jamie Dornan eventually
coming out on top
after achieving major box office success
with Fight Club in 2000 director David
Fincher turned to his next project the
2002 Thriller Panic Room the movie
focuses on a mother and daughter who
must Retreat to a safe room in their new
home after it is invaded by burglars
Venture knew that finding the right
actors would be crucial to the success
of his movie however none of Fincher's
original casting choices ever made it
into the film at first Nicole Kidman and
Hayden Panettiere had been cast as the
mother and daughter but Panettiere
dropped out of the project before a
filming got underway she was replaced by
Kristen Stewart in what was her first
starring role filming for Panic Room
began in January 2001 but Kidman didn't
last long just two weeks after principal
photography began Kidman was hurt on the
set aggravating an old knee injury she
sustained while filming Moulin Rouge
Kidman subsequently left the film to
recover so Fincher had to scramble to
find her replacement meanwhile actor and
director Jody Foster had to shut down
the production on her own movie Flora
Plum after its star Russell Crowe was
also injured with their schedules
suddenly open Foster was tapped to take
on Kidman's role in Panic Room since
Kidman and Crow had already been good
friends for a long time the weirdness of
the situation wasn't lost on Foster she
told film Inc magazine I remember
emailing Russell saying I'm doing
Nicole's movie how ironic is that
when director Steven Spielberg was first
preparing to make Indiana Jones and the
Raiders of the Lost Ark his friend
George Lucas who co-wrote the screenplay
was against the idea of casting Harrison
Ford as the lead at that point Ford had
already starred in three of Lucas's
other films including the first two Star
Wars movies so Lucas had concerns about
working too often with the same actor
instead of Ford Spielberg and Lucas
initially cast Tom Selleck as Indy
Selleck did a screen test for the part
and later explained to Rachel Ray that
he didn't turn down the role as some may
believe I didn't turn it down I earned
the part when Spielberg and Lucas
offered in the part Selleck was under
contract with CBS having just completed
the pilot for Magnum PI Spielberg and
Lucas attempted to negotiate with the
network to borrow selik for their movie
but CBS wouldn't budge and I said well
what are we going to do now and Steve
said well what about Harrison so with
less than three weeks before filming
began Lucas gave in and allowed
Spielberg to cast for the part would go
on to become one of the actor's most
iconic roles
in 1992 Michelle Pfeiffer made waves
when she gave a provocative performance
as Catwoman and Batman Returns however
the part was originally meant for
someone else director Tim Burton had
Cast four-time Academy Award nominee
Annette Benning as Catwoman a decision
that left Pfeiffer heartbroken she would
later explain to The Hollywood Reporter
as a young girl I was completely
obsessed with Catwoman when I heard that
Tim was making the film and Catwoman had
already been cast I was devastated
however Pfeiffer got a chance to make
her childhood dream come true when
Benning became pregnant and was forced
to drop out of the film Burton recast
her in the role and Pfeiffer threw
herself into kickboxing and whip
training in order to give a convincing
performance and unlike Halle Berry's
take on the part in 2004's Catwoman
Pfeiffer earned a claim for the role
when Lord of the Rings director Peter
Jackson was getting ready to make the
2009 Supernatural drama The Lovely Bones
he initially cast Ryan Gosling in the
leading male role Gosling was to play
grieving father Jack Salmon who becomes
obsessed with finding the person
responsible for his teenage daughter's
murder shortly before filming started
Gosling unexpectedly announced his
departure from the film at the time the
actor told parade he left the film
because he had concerns about playing an
older character however the truth is
that Peter Jackson actually fired
Gosling from the movie apparently Ryan
Gosling showed up on set sporting a
scraggly beard and having gained 60
pounds a physical transformation that
the actor hadn't discussed with the
director and I showed up and I said you
look terrible and I said I know isn't
that great no it's not although Gosling
was supposed to be playing a severely
depressed man Jackson fired him for the
unplanned weight gain he was replaced by
Mark Wahlberg who was given the part
just one day before filming began
if we told you that Jean-Claude Van
Damme had originally been cast in 1987's
Predator you might imagine him playing
Arnold Schwarzenegger's role as major
Alan Dutch Schaefer however Van Damme
was supposed to play The Predator
creature at that time the Predator was
supposed to have a much different
fighting style one that would make use
of Van Damme's martial arts skills
what's more the original Predator
costume designed for Van Damme had
backward bending reptile legs and a
protruding head Van Damme who was not
yet a star didn't understand that he was
essentially to be a stuntman for the
duration of the film he had thought that
audiences would get to see his face and
that he'd be able to fight
Schwarzenegger in some hand-to-hand
combat scenes so when Van Damme found
out that this wouldn't be the case he
was angry in the documentary if it
bleeds we can kill it the making of
Predator it was also reported that Van
Damme had passed out while filming
jungle scenes in the hot creature suit
and he's like I hate this head I hate it
I hate it hit it eventually director
John mctiernan scrapped all of the
original plans for the Predator
including Van Damme's casting he was
replaced by the seven foot two inch tall
actor Kevin Peter Hall the costume was
also redesigned into the iconic Predator
that we know today
for Ang Lee's acclaimed 2012 survival
drama Life of Pi the director originally
intended to use a cast that was full of
unknown actors the sole exception to
this was Toby Maguire who was tapped to
play Jan Martell the Canadian author who
wrote the novel Lee's film was based on
Maguire arrived on the set and had
actually filmed all of his scenes but
for Lee the actor was just too
recognizable and stuck out like a sore
thumb amongst the rest of the cast so
the director ultimately cut McGuire from
the movie explaining to The Hollywood
Reporter to be consistent with the other
casting choices made for the film I
decided to go with an entirely
International cast he re-shot all of
McGuire's scenes with Rafe spall who got
a chance to share in life of Pi's Glory
when it received 11 Academy Award
nominations and four wins
when director baz luhrmann took on the
artistic challenge of modernizing
Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet for the
grunge listening Youth of the 90s he
understood the importance of selecting
the right actors for the leading roles
hot off his Oscar nomination for What's
Eating Gilbert Grape the young and
Charming Leonardo DiCaprio was an
obvious choice for the Lovestruck Romeo
his Juliet on the other hand was a more
difficult find although we now know the
role eventually went to my so-called
LifeStar Claire Danes she wasn't the
first or even second choice for the part
originally Lerman had cast Then 14 year
old Natalie Portman the age was fitting
for the original character but when a 21
year old DiCaprio came into the picture
the problematic age Gap quickly became
apparent Portman told the New York Times
in 1996 fox said it looked like Leonardo
DiCaprio was molesting me when we kissed
Lerman agreed saying in a 2022 interview
with the New York Times she was 14 and
when you see Leo in the flesh he's a
tall young man and you just realized she
was too young Natalie was amazing in the
footage but it was too much of a burden
for her at that age Lerman went through
several more months of auditions before
finding Danes although DiCaprio still
had some years on the 17 year old actor
he spoke glowingly of his Romeo and
Juliet co-star telling the New Yorker
she was the only girl that looked me in
the eye on auditions I was always so
happy when I finished doing the love
scenes normally enjoyed by the end of
the day I was just like all is good
after her breakout role as Dorothy Gale
in 1939's The Wizard of Oz Judy Garland
starred in some of Hollywood's biggest
pictures as a result her career reached
Soaring Heights however by the end of
the 1940s Garland's worsening mental
health and dependence on various
substances took a heavy toll on her
career time away from sets and
unpredictable Behavior resulted in
Garland being fired on multiple
occasions from films such as the
Barclays of Broadway and he get your gun
and Royal Wedding Garland was replaced
in another movie after these instances
this time however there was much more
publicity surrounding the incident in
1967 Garland was cast as Helen Lawson in
Valley of the Dolls an ironically
fitting story about women's struggles
with the destructive facets of Fame she
got as far as recording the movie's
original song I'll plant my own tree
before being fired a week into filming
for being under the influence however
Garland's brief co-star Patty Duke had a
different recollection of events writing
in her 1987 autobiography calling Anna
Duke claimed that the studio and
director exploited Garland's condition
for publicity Susan Hayward ultimately
replaced Garland sadly just two years
later the queen of musicals died at the
age of 47 from an accidental overdose
developing a movie from an idea to a
final product often takes years the 2018
biographical drama can you ever forgive
me was no exception but the complicated
11-year Journey the process of getting
financing for the production was a long
one but when director Nicole Halep
Center signed on along with Julianne
Moore everything started coming together
until it all went wrong a week before
filming began variety reported that
Moore withdrew from the project due to
creative differences shortly after Hall
of Center also departed but not before
recasting the part of Lee Israel with
Melissa McCarthy Moore has since come
out with a different version of events
however which she discussed on Watch
What Happens live with Andy Cohen I
didn't leave that movie I was fired were
you yeah yeah Nicole fired me so yeah so
yeah Moore went on to praise McCarthy
proving there was no ill will between
the two Hall of Center was also a
pleased with her replacement director
Marielle Heller heller continued with
Hall of Center screenplay and McCarthy
delivered an oscar-nominated performance
that transformed her career from Comedy
Queen to Serious dramatic Factor
before Eddie Murphy became one of the
biggest actors in Hollywood he was known
for his larger-than-life characters on
Saturday Night Live all that changed
when Beverly Hills Cop launched him into
movie startup much of the movie we know
today can be attributed to Murphy's
comedic chops but believe it or not it
was almost Sylvester Stallone who played
the role of quick-witted Detroit cop
Axel Foley two weeks before filming
commenced Stallone left the project
unsatisfied with the movie's comedic
tones however before he turned the roll
down altogether Stallone did some
rewrites of his own to better suit his
set of acting skills according to the
actor his rewrites were reminiscent of
the opening scene from Saving Private
Ryan Stallone recalled in a 2006
interview with Ain't It Cool News
needless to say they drop kicked me and
my script out of the office and the rest
is history
building off the success of his feature
directorial debut the 40 year old virgin
Judd Apatow directed the film knocked up
a raunchy romantic comedy about an
unplanned pregnancy between two clashing
personalities casting Seth Rogen as the
male lead was no problem Apatow had
worked with Rogan on many occasions in
the past and the two became close
friends in the process however in
Apatow's boys only comedy Circle finding
the right actor for the female lead
wasn't as easy Anne Hathaway ended up
taking on the role before dropping out
due to the nature of the movie's birth
scene things eventually fell into place
when Catherine Heigl stepped in to
replace her there was no denying the
natural on-stream chemistry Heigl shared
with co-star Rogan or her ability to
hold her own in the mail-centric flick
in 2013 it was announced that the
Beloved bear from children's literature
Paddington was getting his very own
live-action film Colin Firth was
originally tapped to bring the famous
bear to life but when principal
photography wrapped and the film went
into post-production that opinion
changed as the CGI animators finalized
paddington's look there was a disconnect
between the Bear's youthful appearance
and forth's dramatic older voice
10. Paddington Paddington Paddington
director Paul King told Entertainment
Weekly Colin was the first to say I just
don't know that I have this within me
and we slowly sadly agreed and with that
Firth voluntarily withdrew from the
project he was replaced by Ben Wishaw
just a few months before the movie's
theatrical release
considering the huge success of the
first two movies in the Transformers
franchise director Michael Bay didn't
take Megan Fox's firing from
Transformers Dark of the Moon lightly
luckily for Bay the main character's
love interest isn't what drives ticket
sales in an action movie about
automobile robots with a simple
off-screen breakup Fox was replaced by a
new girlfriend played by Rosie
Huntington Whiteley why exactly was Fox
cut in a 2009 interview with Wonderland
Fox made some comments about Bay's onset
Behavior comparing him to a certain
fascist dictator the actor told the
outlet he's like Napoleon and he wants
to create this insane Infamous madman
reputation he wants to be like Hitler on
his sets and he is this hyperbole didn't
go unpunished in addition to having
qualms with her work ethic they claimed
in an interview with GQ that executive
producer Steven Spielberg demanded her
firing Bay told the magazine I wasn't
hurt because I know that's just Megan
Megan loves to get a response and she
does it in kind of the wrong way I'm
sorry Megan I'm sorry I made you work 12
hours I'm sorry that I'm making you show
up on time movies are not always warm
and fuzzy although Fox was out of a job
surely she was relieved to be parting
ways with a boss she deemed unpleasant
meanwhile Transformers Dark of the Moon
grossed more than one billion dollars at
the box office
the Twilight Saga will always be
remembered for popularizing the trend of
Supernatural romances in the late 2000s
and early 2010s little girls everywhere
dreamed of finding their own sparkly
vampire to sweep them off their feet and
save them from the dangers of
bloodthirsty nomadic vampires in the
first two installments of the series
Twilight and New Moon Rochelle lafe
portrayed the thirstiest of them all the
vengeful vampire Victoria her fiery red
hair and ruthless desire for Bella's
blood made her the perfect villain and a
fan favorite so when news broke that
Victoria was being recast it came as a
surprise to everyone including LeFevre
LeFevre told Access Hollywood I was
stunned by summit's decision to recast
the rule of Victoria for her Clips I
turned down several other film
opportunities and in accordance with my
contractual rights accepted only roles
that would involve very short shooting
schedules one of those roles was for a
project called Barney's version which
overlapped 10 days with eclipse's
three-month shooting schedule Summit
responded by claiming LeFevre withheld
disclosing the scheduling conflict for
more than a month feeling as though
lefevre's actions put the production at
risk Bryce Dallas Howard was has to take
her place the circumstances around it
had nothing to do with us and she's
she's awesome relief didn't lose out on
too much since her character's death at
the end of the movie Would Have Made It
her last appearance anyway
in the Sci-Fi Action movie Demolition
Man Sylvester Stallone and Wesley Snipes
go head to head in an effects driven
game of cops and robbers in the year
2032. in the film Sandra Bullock placed
alone's colleague in love interest
however it was Lori Petty who was
originally cast to play the futuristic
cop but after a few days of shooting
Petty was out and Bullock was in the
initial reasoning behind Paddy's
departure was cited as creative
differences Petty on the other hand
believed it had to do with her and
Stallone's lack of compatibility
needless to say Bullock ultimately
lucked out as Petty's replacement Not
only was it her first big budget feature
but it also led to her next breakout
role in the action movie Speed who knows
what direction Bullock's career would
have taken if not for this casting
mishap
during the making of the Back to the
Future Trilogy Robert zemeckis and Bob
Gale had no problem replacing actors
when needed they did it with Eric Stoltz
Melora Hardin and again with Claudia
Wells but there was one replacement that
maybe wasn't so obvious on the set of
Back to the Future tensions were high
between crisp and Glover who played
George McFly and the creators lover has
stated that he was unhappy with the
movie's ending and when he raised
questions about it he was met with
hostility he told the AV club the
reality was that they did not want me
back in the film it caused me to not be
in the sequels Glover was offered less
than half of what his co-stars were
making and when he tried to renegotiate
they reduced the offer by twenty five
thousand dollars Glover walked away and
was replaced by Jeffrey Wiseman who wore
Prosthetics to resemble Glover because
of both the Prosthetics as well as
deliberate techniques to obscure wise
men many never realized it wasn't Glover
on screen for Back to the Future 2 and
3. Glover ultimately took legal action
to protect his likeness the lawsuit was
settled out of court and the screen
actor's guild later added a clause
regarding the illicit use of actors like
weaknesses
when domestic abuse allegations came out
against Johnny Depp Warner Brothers was
forced to act by asking death to resign
from his role as Gellert kinderwald in
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of
Dumbledore the studio had to move fast
to find a replacement and gave Mass
Mickelson just two days to decide if he
could fill the role director David Yates
told The Hollywood Reporter I wanted
Mass to explore a version of Grindelwald
that suited his strengths as an actor
and that inevitably meant a departure
from what Johnny brought to the role
just a couple of months after the
movie's release a jury sided with Deb in
his highly publicized defamation lawsuit
against his ex-wife Amber Heard once the
trial was over Nicholson gave Depp fans
hope when he told deadline obviously
well now the course has changed he won
the suit the court case so let's see if
he comes back he might I'm a big fan of
Johnny I think he's an amazing actor I
think he did a fantastic job however any
potential sequels have reportedly been
stalled until further notice
foreign